[Music]
yeah AJ it elided to meet you nice to
meet you thank you for coming over here
to talk about a subject dear to my heart
to your heart you spent a little more
time thinking about this that I have use
this as a big session for you to help me
dilemma way to approach this yes what
we're both parents of four kids of
differing ages and this book is
fantastic because not only is it about
the health of the children that we're
all trying to raise as effectively as
possible
it's about paying attention to our own
well-being in this equation how dare you
write a book about yes making sure that
the parents are happy right we are
supposed to put all of our energy and
self and everything into our children
right until we're bleeding and we're
left laying on the side of the road yeah
yeah yeah and a ride to their next
appointment or something no it's it is
crazy how as a society how much we're
feeling that right now that it's our job
to put to sort of sacrifice ourselves
and our well-being in our time and our
energy and our money and all of our
resources are post to go straight into
our children who I don't know are
presumably supposed to somehow grow up
and commit the same exact cycle for
their kids I don't know one of the
questions I like to ask people as well
if your kid's life looks just like yours
when they're your age will you be
thrilled mmm and if the answer is yes
then you know that guess basically carry
on but if there are things where you're
like well uh you know I was kind of
thinking she spends a lot of time
playing the violin now it'd be nice if
she were still enjoying that and I've
lost mine I don't know it wouldn't it's
an it's an interesting sort of a thought
kind of gut reaction that I would
imagine a lot of people have to that
thought is while I'm doing all of this
of
they can have a better life so that they
don't do what I'm like I'm trying to
instill in them or provide them with
everything that they can have so that
they can transcend the circumstances
that I'm in to live differently and
better I think we get to do that for
ourselves too and I think for our kids I
mean if we need to put this all on to
our kids you know if we sort of need to
put make them the focus of what we're
doing and why we're doing it it's
actually much better for them to see the
adults in their lives having a
productive happy Pleasant joyful
experience otherwise how are they gonna
learn to do that and why would they even
want to I mean sometimes I'll definitely
look at my kid's life and go man I
wouldn't like it if somebody just drove
me around all the time and like clapped
when I did fun things that would be
great it's somehow not how things have
worked it maybe my mom could come and
she could drive yeah I don't think
that's gonna work out so well but it's
it's really this is like this is our
time right we've got twenty plus years
of raising our families and being with
them and being all together in that same
house and and sort of having this
experience of being a family I just want
us to make it great for everybody yeah I
mean just hearing you say that and
simply by virtue of the fact that you
wrote this book makes me feel better
but it but it also I can't help but also
feel like I've been like a little bit
there's that little bit of like guilt
you know that creeps up like you're a
bad parent if you're not if you're not
giving over all of yourself for the
betterment of your kids you know what I
mean and maybe that's social programming
that we need to transcend and overcome
well I think it's social programming so
let's let's look at like um let's we'll
go ahead we'll take it from the kids
perspective so one of my mantras is that
you can be happy when your kids are not
and that definitely makes some people
kind of hook you know make you feel a
little you know a little step back there
wait no I can't I can only be as happy
as my unhappiest kid right that's the
saying I can't be happy when they're not
but um you know let's sort of let's
let's talk this let's let's parse this
out so if you're the kid and things are
going wrong for you you know like you
didn't get invited to the birthday party
and you're 11 and your mom is losing her
mind because you didn't get invited to
birthday party a couple of things are
happening first of all you're like whoa
maybe this is a big deal I mean I was
thinking it was an 11 year old birthday
party but maybe it's huge secondly our
kids don't actually want us to be
unhappy I mean all right sometimes it
feels like they do especially at two
o'clock in the morning or whatever but
they really don't so here's your child
going hmm when I tell my mom that things
like that happen she gets really upset
maybe I shouldn't tell her or oh my dad
got really you know like when I didn't
make the team it really freaked him out
so maybe like maybe I should maybe I
should either pretend it doesn't matter
to me or not try out because like I
don't like to upset my parents so those
are some unintentional consequences that
they're feeling
plus you know our kids don't need the
burden of our happiness on top of theirs
that's the bigger point right yes I
think you know having that kind of
extreme emotional reaction to that
situation even if it's well intended is
only sort of putting you're just you're
just adding to the problem you're
amplifying something yeah and like you
carry that into adult life I mean if
you're 35 and getting a divorce then
things aren't going great for you you
don't also need your father to be
falling apart because you're getting a
divorce like you don't you know you want
to be able to go okay I'm having a mess
right now but you know my parents are
there okay they're at their even-keel
and I can look to them and I can I can
go to that I mean and that's true when
you're very young to you you want you
want to be like oh I'm having this crazy
emotional teenage thing but my parents
are you know they got a tennis game I
mean they're here for me
they're empathetic they're sympathetic
you know they're trying to help but also
they're showing me like that there's
gonna be a live past my crazy teenage
experience and that you know also that
my family is here from unit
for a way that they're not sort of all
wrapped up and whether or not I get the
lead in the player yeah I mean there's
some something just fundamentally very
unhealthy about a parent who is overly
emotionally invested in the vicissitudes
of their child's daily emotional
interior life yeah there has to be a
healthy boundary between that and and
you know Julie my always been great
about this like I've learned I've
learned from her when I when our kids
were younger if something is upsetting
our child or you know the a child is
pitching a fit over something or
something like that so just not buy-in
just be like okay I see a really upset
but to be completely unfettered alright
I think demonstrates like a strength or
a level of stability that is a buffer
like if you buy into that mania then
you're just you're accelerating this
whole process it's there's something
really unhealthy about your feeding the
beats
yes exactly is what you're doing and
then they're taking your emotions and
they're gobbling them up and then
they're feeding back to you and you're
gobbling them up and everything just you
know raising my hands here but
everything just goes up and up and up to
this other level we call that you don't
have to go in there in our house because
one of our kids used to have her
tantrums in a closet
we just we were literally stand out
dinner's ready for you pretty much
yeah we would stand out there looking at
each other going are you going in there
I got in there and eventually it just
became like you know what we're not
supposed to go in there it's it's better
because we you know I mean this is not
like I know all the things this is more
I've talked to a lot of experts have
done a lot of research and I've got a
fair you know I've got some experience
and all of that is piled into this book
and that was one where we used to go in
there you know we used to sort of throw
ourselves right in with it and either
try to fix it or yell because why are
you getting so upset over this stupid
thing or you know just there's sort of a
lot of different reactions that you can
happen to a kid because I've said that
feels like you're parenting yeah right
yeah feels like you're doing something
you're actually working at
cross-purposes right sometimes nothing
is the best something right so let's
take a step back I mean why why write
this book
like what didn't I mean you were you've
been a columnist for The New York Times
for many years leading up to the point
of writing this book writing about
parenting writing about well-being in
the family for mother lode and then it
became well family right like you
rebranded it what inspired you to to to
even write this book from well I wanted
to go I wanted to go deeper into our
experience then you can go in like a
series of 800 to a thousand word pieces
and it really started with you know I
I've written a lot I've written more
about the societal and the cultural and
the policy parts of parent you know sort
of the reasons that that these are the
reasons that things are hard or that we
perceive things as being hard when
they're not and some of the reasons that
things are objectively difficult I mean
you know realistically we talked a
really great game in this country about
how we're all about family but it's
really hard to find daycare and you know
if you have a baby and you have a job
those are two things that are not
necessarily compatible you know and yet
we expect you to do it and that's minute
sort of a really it's a different
conversation so I thought about writing
about that but that has been written
about and really you know brilliantly by
people that I respect and I just kept
sort of thinking well I'm a part of this
movement to try to change both the
policy that in fact families and also
the way that we talk about family and
the way that we support them but that's
not gonna sit on asleep it's not gonna
help me we can get all the family leave
that we want that ship has sailed for me
and for many of my fellow parenting so
what I wanted or fellow parents what I
wanted to talk about is like how can we
make our day-to-day better right now
with the cards that we're dealt with the
fact that sucker is insane and you know
your your school expects you to be doing
Kumaon and violin class thinks that
you're gonna play the CD over and over
in the car until your head explodes like
how can we sort of take you down the
street is always doing it better Oh
Suzie down let's don't even get into
Susie down the street I mean their way
she's kids got her kids in their trapeze
classes and all that stuff it just makes
me crazy
right
well what I what I really kind of like
love and appreciate you know about the
kind of core theme of this book which
which really boils down to this idea
that that you can't take care of others
unless you take care of yourself which
flies in the face of like our instincts
especially as parents to kind of
sacrifice ourselves for the for the
betterment of our loved ones but it
really is true like you have to tend to
your own garden you have to put that
oxygen mask on first before you put it
on the child right that it's just become
such a saying that we've sort of I feel
like we've started to just kind of give
it lip service like oh well yeah I mean
I'm taking care of myself I eat healthy
you know I go to a couple of exercise
classes but um you know to really have
you know to really model a great and
full life for our kids and also to just
have it for ourselves because we you
know we are we're worthy of putting time
into ourselves and making our own
decisions about like sort of how we want
to spend Saturday and where we want to
go for vacation and even what we want to
have for dinner it doesn't have to
revolve around somebody else you know
whether that's your kids or your parents
or air or anything signing your parents
your partner or anything I it's just I
feel like um you know I talked to this
this great expert Rick Hansen you
probably know him he's the
neuropsychologist he's the author of
hardwired for happiness and he's written
a lot about how you know human brains
are really kind of they're wired to look
for the bad stuff right because bad
stuff is dangerous and we got to look
for those Tigers we got to remember
where the Tigers are and he's his idea
is that the more spine we spend soaking
in like the good stuff the more we can
train our brains not to freak out about
imaginary Tigers because there aren't
that many but the point the reason I'm
sort of telling that story is that at
some point he said to me you know
sometimes I feel like Americans are
afraid to be happy and that really soak
it in for me like I don't want to be
afraid to be happy I want to I want to I
want to go for it I want to like grab
all the happy that I can
that doesn't mean you know everybody
else out of my way I'm gonna get my own
happy it means you know let's let's
build something that that's wonderful
for all of us where do you think that
fear of unhappiness comes wrong well we
really um you know we kind of we don't
think it's worth our attention right
I mean being happy how is that person I
know and we're supposed to be like you
know the life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness but how is happiness
productive how is happiness is improving
the economy how is happiness improving
the political situation or the you know
the the suffering of other human beings
like I don't know I think I feel like we
really we again it's a sort of one of
those ideas we give we give some words
to it but then we see it as an
indulgence it's that same thing that
keeps us from taking all of our vacation
time or from really shutting our
computers down at night and actually
doing something instead of sitting there
with your email in front of you in front
of you and you know Netflix on the TV
and and sort of half working and half
watching yeah well there's the the
theoretical aspect of what you're saying
which I think we can all kind of agree
with yeah I get that like I need to be
happy and blah blah blah and then
there's the practical implementation
yeah trying to make this happen
and so I'm just imagining somebody
listening to this okay
yeah I get it but like I have two jobs
and I've got kids that go to different
schools and carpool and soccer practice
and by the time you know I get home and
then I got to make dinner
like I'm depleted I'm exhausted it's
literally just a race to the finish line
each night so I can crash and repeat the
cycle once again right how do we break
yeah out of this that that is exactly
the thing so I mean you know what I want
to hear it that way that's that's the
experience that I sort of started from
when well I didn't have two jobs I only
had the one job the one paying job but
that's what I think that's where a lot
of us start is sort of we get up in the
morning and we lace up our skates and we
start to go and we run all day and then
we get to the end and we just sort of
collapse into bed and if we've got a
partner we start arguing them but them
about you know whose day sucked more
because you know
that's that's what we're seeing around
us so I have a bunch of answers for that
and one of them is it's just this
question of why we're running so hard
and where we're running to you know
we've really we fill our days like we
fill our kids days or they fill their
own days because there's really I mean
there's there's so much great stuff like
I want to do all the great things I want
to learn to surf and and learn to draw
cartoons and take violin lessons and do
but you can't you can't do all the
things and sometimes we get a little
caught up in the idea that we can you
know that we can and that we should or
that we should provide our kids the
opportunity to do all the things but
what we're forgetting then is that we
actually really both want and value and
need time to do none of the things this
is like this is sort of part of my whole
get more sleep have happier mornings
make everything slow down but a lot a
lot a lot comes back to the idea of
protecting playtime downtime and family
time for our kids and for ourselves
because a lot of what we forget when we
schedule all the all the all the magnet
and it is magnificence like it really is
fun it's great that we can give our kids
tutors after school that to help them
grow and you know that they can be in a
net or sometimes they have to be in an
after-school program because we you know
we're still at work but then afterwards
we feel like well we can still get them
to football practice you know we don't
want them to miss out on that god forbid
our free time yeah exactly so what we
forget is that we we really we want and
we crave and we need that free time and
a lot of the time we take that free time
and we suck it out of our sleep and then
we get more unhappy because then the
next day we get up mm-hmm and we didn't
get enough sleep and the whole cycle
just starts all over again
yeah we're in this culture in which we
feel compelled to schedule our children
to the hilt and that
bad parents if we don't do so and we've
lost the art of doing nothing and the
beauty and appreciation for just free
time of playtime because it provokes
something inside of us that makes us
feel like we're not doing a good job
well we're scared that we're scared and
it's not unreasonable because you know
when you look at your kids and and sort
of the world that they're gonna go in
add into what this there's there are
some numbers out there that I don't
remember that some huge percentage of
the jobs our kids will have our jobs
that don't even exist yet
so how can we possibly prepare them for
that college applications are I totally
didn't like whatever I don't know what
your experience was implying for college
but I can tell you your children's will
not be that no of course not changing so
right now we're dealing with an
incredibly antiquated educational system
we don't know what things are gonna look
like
in 20 years I'm not sure that we're
adequately preparing kids for this
futuristic world that you know exceeds
our ability to comprehend with the
advent of AI like I just did a podcast
with you've all know a Harare and he
said the most he's like our education
system is broken the most important
thing to teach and to learn is emotional
and professional flexibility like be
able to have incredible interpersonal
skills to be able to like ride the wave
of change by being resilient right and
so multiple thousands of parents just
heard that and thought where can I get a
class and in resilience school it's
because we're in charge yes because we
want to control that okay if that's the
most important thing I want to make sure
my kids learn it and unfortunately a lot
of what our kids are gonna need to know
is how to make decisions for themselves
how to decide how to decide for
themselves how to spend their time how
to find something that they can get into
deeply and and you know sort of focus on
and concentrate on and instead of giving
them the opportunity to explore and the
space to explore and the time sort of
dopes around and do do nothing we want
to fill their turn
with with structured activities that are
going to make sure that they've at least
learned something I mean I get that I
don't want to I don't want to sound like
my kids are all you know out blowing
dandelions right now they're they're not
I don't know what time it is exactly but
they're at the you know various
practices and sort of think yeah I mean
a lot of that is being motivated by fear
right that fear that somebody else is
getting ahead or they will be unprepared
or that you're not measuring up as a
parent this is the one class or the one
test that's gonna make the difference
and you know my special snowflake is
gonna get into the drift if it gets into
the Ivy League versus the drift that
doesn't and on the the snowflake thing
is a big thing too I mean we're so
terrified of them being hurt or injured
because we are generally afraid I mean
when I was a kid look it was a different
time granted but you know I just in the
summer I got on my bike in the morning
and left and came home at dinner my
parents dropped me off at the
neighborhood pool and I just hung out
all day and I came home at night right
yeah and I think it's a crime actually
in some animals you know if you're
unsupervised and I don't know how I feel
about that like I understand we need to
be well and if you are that parent your
kids just your your your kids as friends
probably aren't so you know you have the
only kid riding around the neighborhood
on their bike while everyone this is
it's a problem I mean it's it's really
hard we're sort of all sort of psyching
each other up together it's hard to
fight against this I don't you know I
don't want to pretend that this is that
it's easy to say well you know we're
gonna step back and we're gonna try to
to prioritize happiness and balance when
everybody else is kind of like doing
what's called the rug race rug rat race
but if we can agree that it's important
to instill in our children a sense of
Independence and a sense of self
sovereignty and self confidence we have
to relent like we have to take a step
back and provide some modicum of freedom
and decision making on their behalf
which i think is is scary on some level
for a lot of parents especially because
a lot of parents then say well all my
kid's gonna do with that is like
get on their phone or be play video
games maybe that's true right and so how
do we do that responsibly you know I
honestly think that we kind of they need
actually enough time to get bored with
those things and that is really hard I
know now I don't know that they can
there is no boredom anymore I don't know
do you know if you if you if you have
like if you have hours every day that
are available to you to do whatever you
want as a kid you're gonna spend some of
them on your electronics and on your
screens and on and all that sort of
thing
I don't know if anyone's willing to do
this experiment but I eventually those
things get old you know kids start
looking around for other things I mean
am I am I giving night my kids that
opportunities sometimes yes sometimes
now you know am I going upstairs and
saying stop playing fortnight now yes I
absolutely am but yeah it's you we have
to sort of we have to give them the
space like when we were kids we for us
it was TV like how much TV I mean so
some parents were like no TV you know my
kid watches no TV and some parents were
like an hour a day and some parents are
like go for it all the love boats you
can watch or whatever then you have you
know a list Hollywood directors talking
about how they were latch kit keys or
just watched television all day long or
another you know making massive movies
in Hollywood so it's it's not a simple
it's a real equation it's really really
not and I think you know we have to take
some risks we have to accept that when
we tell you our kids well you know you
can do whatever you want on Sunday but
I'm gonna you know schedule the heck out
of you on Saturday or whatever that
they're not gonna spend some day in ways
that are what we would choose for them
that's the whole point they need to
learn to choose for themselves yeah I
think one of the the differentiating
things between television and and
screens is I mean
beyond the obvious that it's a
supercomputer that can do many more
things it's more active than passive
compared to television but it is the
device by which the younger generation
you know not only communicates with each
other as do we as adults but but it is
the it is it is really the way that
they're going to make their way in the
world like they have to be fluent right
in the language of these devices so the
solution isn't like remove it I know
with Mike with my younger kids it would
take a very long time for them to get
bored and say okay I'm done with the
screen I want to go do something else
like it's so addictive it's so
compelling but if you restrict that time
and say okay now you're off suddenly
they're painting or drawing right we're
going outside things that they're
they're not inclined to naturally choose
on their own when they have this screen
in front of them yeah I mean it is it is
a compelling option I feel like when
when kids are little or when they're
younger you really have to you know the
adult needs to be in control of it the
thing is that as they get older and they
start you know becoming teenagers and
getting into high school we need to
start relaxing our control while talking
to them about taking some control
because otherwise they're gonna hit
college in their freshman year and
they're gonna walk out your door and
they're gonna sit down in front of the
ps4 they take with them in the dorm room
you know they're not gonna move for for
a year because they haven't sort of had
any experience with trying to moderate
them that themselves I this this is so
hard and it's hard in part because we
didn't our parents didn't have to do it
we didn't experience it you know the
screens are obviously different than TV
if for no other reason then you couldn't
really watch TV 24 hours a day when a
lot of us were little and then you've
gotten to the point where you could but
it's not like you like it was good TV
how many Leave It to Beaver reruns can
you possibly want also so right so these
are different they are more compelling
but I think an important thing to
remember is that our teenagers are part
of our national conversation about how
these devices are going to be a part of
our lives so they're thinking about it
too
you know they're not I don't know any
sixteen year olds that are like and what
I really want to do with the next three
hours is be on my Instagram now that
doesn't mean that they won't be but
they're aware that that's not like the
best choice
yeah something nourishing yeah and
they're talking to each other about it
and they're talking to their
pediatricians and they're talking with
their teachers and they're writing
papers and they're trying to solve this
problem which is going to be theirs as a
generation in a big way they're working
on it they really are so I think we
should feel a little less panicked about
sort of turning that over to them I feel
like I'm interested in your reaction of
this like I feel for me I feel like two
of the most important things that I want
to instill in my kids are a strong sense
of self whether that manifests in
independence or just self-assuredness
self confidence just an independent
security in their own being and also to
the extent that this is possible I don't
know if it is to help guide them towards
something that they feel passionate
about that they that makes them feel
alive whatever that thing is because I
feel like if they have a motor that is
self generating that that feels like
half the equation is solved right then
and there and it has to come from within
themselves but I feel like as a parent
part of my job is to when they identify
something that lights them up they kind
of move in and support that or help kind
of like fertilize that soil so that like
little sprout can bloom right I think
the most I honestly think that the
biggest thing that you can do for both
of those is to have those things for
yourselves for yourself and your partner
as well to set an example of being a
person in the world who has something
that they that they choose to do sort of
above you know that really lights them
up like you said and also someone who is
not super concerned about how others
view them or you know you know how what
the neighbors think and that sort of
thing too too
to be that strong person yourself and
also to have those strong interests
yourself if we look back at that sort of
I mean you're a person who has that and
so am I so if you sort of look back at
well what helped me to get there the
answer I'm just guessing but the answer
is probably not that your parents were
driving you to these things that you
felt passionately about the answers that
you had time to find it and when you
found it you pursued it and probably
some of that came from maybe seeing
other people in your lives and maybe
life and maybe it wasn't your parents
seeing other people find things and
pursue them the thing about passion for
our kids as we can't we can't find it
for them and we can't sign them up for
it and if we sign them up for too many
things that might be their passion how
are they gonna you know what if their
passion is glassblowing
you know you could you didn't sign them
up for that I mean how will they how
will they find it if if all of their
hours are filled it's a great point
being you know being ourselves and being
that person ourselves is is honestly the
best thing that we can do along with
supporting them in their interests but
also letting them sort of let go of
interests as you know even if they've
spent ten years playing baseball which
at this point you know your 13 year old
could easily have done that doesn't
necessarily mean they need to keep
playing baseball through high school
that's not a failure if they decide oh
they want to walk away no it gives them
room to find to find their thing which
is probably not baseball it's been a
wild kind of journey that my family has
been on and and yes you're correct like
I'm very blessed I get to do this thing
that does light me up that that makes me
very excited every day I'm incredibly
grateful for the opportunities that I
have but to get to this point I had to
go from a dark place of having a much
more traditional career hmm
walking away from that and having to
endure many years of difficulty and
hardship to get to this place so now
it's all great but I
had to I put my family through a lot
like it to this place and I and I've
I've had to work through like a lot of
guilt no not over that because I
couldn't you know buy the things that
Suzy was buying you know I couldn't take
the kids on this vacation I couldn't you
know we had cars repossessed like there
was a lot of humiliating things that I
it was very very difficult and I spent a
lot of time like feeling really badly
about that and we have two boys that are
now 22 and 23 and they were the ones who
were kind of old enough to have an
awareness of what was going on our girls
were kind of too young and it's been
interesting to have conversations with
them about that now
and what's interesting is that they'll
say they say like yeah it was hard like
there were parts of that that were that
really sucked but but they do have some
gratitude for it because they got to see
somebody take control of their life to
do something that they felt strongly
about and they got to see how hard that
is like in a world of entitled young
people who feel like they just deserve
to be rich and famous they saw how
difficult it was to like make veterans
transition and to build something and
they're like that was incredibly
valuable like they're artists they're
trying to be musicians and they're like
they realize like this is gonna be
difficult you know this is right he's
not gonna just get handed to me yeah and
it was such a it was a you know is
beautiful to hear that I still feel like
I've done these other things but I do
think that there's there is value in
that and I guess what I'm trying to say
is is for somebody who's listening who
feels like they can't do what moves them
because there'll be negative financial
ramifications that perhaps there is a
way through and the lesson that you're
teaching your kids is you know there is
value in pursuing something that you
care about like you don't have to settle
for a job for the purposes of making
sure that you can pay the Netflix bill
right or if you choose to do that if you
used to say you know what you know
accounting is not my passion but it is
what I do so that I can you know do what
the thing that I love on the weekend and
on the other you know in the other time
to to to embrace that as an active
choice that you're because that's an
okay choice too right I mean we can't we
can't all make the right choices but
what we're showing our kids is I make
decisions that you know affect all of
our lives and then I look for the good
you know I look for the things about
this experience that I'm having that I'm
enjoying that I'm appreciating and I
find those things and I share them with
you and you know we all go out and you
know we try to sort of enjoy I don't
know I'm reaching for like a thing that
that anybody can can do but you know I
go to work because I choose to get the
paycheck so that after work
you know we can choose to hike every
weekend or whatever you know and maybe
everybody makes different choices but
the important thing to show our kids I
think is that we're not just sort of
letting life fall where where it may
we're not just accepting and if we want
to make a change we make a change mmm
but I think you know I wanted to go back
to something that you said which was
about how your road included some some
darkness I think the thing that's really
hard for us as parents and this is hard
for me so this is not like me the
experts saying I'm going to do this in
its gonna because I haven't done this
yet our kids are probably gonna go
through some darkness yeah it blows you
know like but on the other hand really
really do you want to raise the kid
who's never so much as lost a balloon
like do you especially in an environment
where resilience crazy is gonna be
important yeah do you want to send that
kid out in the world you know do you
want to send out the college roommate
that doesn't even know that when you put
the dishes in the sink that fairies
don't come you know we don't we don't we
don't actually we're not doing anybody a
service if we give our kids the happy
unicorn rainbow childhood we're doing
them a service if we give them the real
childhood you know and the real
experience of being part of our our real
families in our real lives yeah all
right so I have a scenario okay
present you with for your advice so
we're in a very interesting moment right
now our family our two older boys have
moved out so it's just my wife and our
two girls who are 14 and 11 our 11 year
old goes to school around the corner our
14 year old just got into this
performing arts high school locks up
that she spent a year preparing her
portfolio for she's a visual artist and
against tremendous odds was accepted and
she just started ninth grade at this
well this school is east of downtown it
is a two-hour drive from our house so we
have been doing a lot of game theory
around how to solve this equation and
and and and maintain the cohesion of our
family unit should we you know take
turns driving should we like whatever we
spun all the scenarios and we ultimately
decided that the best way to maintain
the health and integrity of our family
and support our daughter is to rent an
apartment downtown so we did that I'm
very blessed to be able to do that yeah
but my wife and I and this is just
starting like we're only in our faith of
this my wife and I have now had to take
turns or get to take turns spending time
with her our older daughter downtown
while the other one is here tending to
the other one so we're now we're in this
situation where were ships in the night
both single parents to one child looking
turns going back and forth yeah and the
the the kind of scenario that's
presented itself or the the choice that
we have is to say this is unbelievably
burdensome how hard how difficult it's
never going to work or just
what an incredible look what our
daughter created because of what she's
manifested we now get to have this
adventure where we get to experience
what it's like to be in downtown LA
right and and have a different kind of
lifestyle experience well we support her
in her pursuit of her dream in the way
that in many ways our family and our
kids really had to support Julie and I
in the pursuit of our dream right but
what I want to do what I want to make
sure that I do is is carve out that time
for family and to make sure that you
know because there's still even with the
back and forth there's still all this
driving it's insane to make sure that
we're still functional professionally
and and with respect like our marriage
so that we can make all of this work and
be happy and functional right Wow I mean
that's that's so exciting for your
daughter and it sounds like she really
made it happen
herself totally did she's very she's
very self-sufficient and be emancipated
like she'd be like I'll just stay down
here and eat post mates you know post me
I'm like all right well you're 14 that's
not happening yeah and you probably
don't have the financial resources to
bring that off your table now
so yeah I that I think that you're right
that that if you're gonna go all-in with
the daughter downtown that it needs to
be like it you know this is an adventure
we're doing this thing but realistically
like you and and your wife are making
huge sacrifices so that she can she can
go to this high school and your other
daughter is making a sacrifice to which
she presumably did not sign up yes she
didn't have a choice in the matter we'll
know which is okay kids don't always you
know you don't always get a choice and
and presumably she'll get her turn yeah
I would I mean one of the things I think
is I sort of hear the story is that I
would make sure that that daughter is
also making some sacrifices like you
know she may not be able to do all or
maybe you know she needs to be getting
her own
you know finding rides or finding
friends that she can stay with her you
know some of the time you can't fall in
it can't fall yeah that's right I mean
yeah yeah and we're having that
conversation a little bit
yeah but yeah I'll report so far so good
but well you know the difficult that the
hardest part is you know I'll get a
email or a phone call hey can you do
this thing it's in like six weeks from
now on this day right I'm like well I
don't know if I'm gonna do where am I
gonna be done and where am I gonna be
I'm not sure you know so having to
figure all that out but I think with
some just communication we can solve all
of this right it's a challenge I mean
we're up for it it's cool we'll see how
it goes well you're just racing the
Drivetime crazy I mean that's you know
what I talk a lot about like don't let
your kid to do things that are well I
don't I don't really I mean my kids all
play travel hockey that means that my
husband or I we spend I mean we spend
two hours in the car with one or two yes
absolutely and one of the things that I
have made a conscious decision around is
exactly what you were talking about
about the adventure the apartment is you
know it's very easy to go into this
stuff and be like oh this is the last
place I want to be this is awful I can't
believe I have to drive two hours in the
snow to you know stand in a cold rink
for 40 minutes while you play a high and
then drive back this is stupid but the
truth is that there's actually nowhere I
would rather be given that you are this
child and that you wanted to do this
thing and that I want to support you and
I don't you know I don't give you
everything by by any means but this is
something that we can do yeah so we're
doing it and we're gonna do it in you
know in a joyful and open instead of
making everyone like sort of a sucker
for who are we kidding especially when
it is snow but and I think I'm sure some
days that that downtown piece is gonna
be like a huge slog for you guys and you
know she's gonna know that you're so
lucky that you can that you can make it
happen but that's okay it's okay you
like you've you've built a world where
you can do that for your
and you can enjoy that you can do it and
how do we you know as kids become
teenagers and a 14 year old daughter
yeah levan year-old daughter is gonna be
a teen soon and I'm concerned about
maintaining open communication right
like making sure that they feel safe and
and and want to talk about what's going
on like we were we did a great job with
the boys with that girls is this has a
different thing you know you see as they
age up and become peope doesn't and that
their interior lives start to be closer
themselves a little bit and not it they
don't want to talk about everything
that's going on and there's that
compulsion as a parent if you're gonna
spend an hour in a car that you gotta
like make this conversation happen right
right what's going on and it's like
nothing ever how's everything fine okay
and then okay do I like press here do I
just let it go how do i as a parent try
to you know create an environment that
is most conducive to productive healthy
communication right well what what I
what I see and this is this is me this
is me you know reporting on what I've
reported on this is what I'm seeing
around me is that kids who are
communicative stay communicative as they
get to be tonight and kids who are you
know sort of more keep things more to
themselves
unfortunately sort of stay that way that
that isn't something that you can you
know that you can change and that the
best things to do are to have a lot of
conversations around a lotta like sort
of - you know maybe you feel that Drive
time with with podcasts that start
communication you know that start
conversations
maybe you set a rule that they I mean
this is not a rule in our family it's
just more so it happens that the only
that the child who rides in the front
seat most is not a front is not a phone
child you know he has one but he'll talk
and it has occurred to me that I need to
actually make a rule as the others move
up into the front seat that if you're
gonna ride in the front seat with me you
can't do it down everyone
it's like then you have these competing
interests like everyone wants to be in
the front seat but they also want to be
on their phone you know if you're up
there you you have to do your part you
have to talk to the driver you have to
be entertaining company I mean within
reason you know can you answer your
friends text and tell them when you're
gonna be there absolutely but you know
can you control the radio and force me
to listen to them to nothing but hits
one only if I'm in the mood
so making I guess making sort of
establishing expectations especially as
your kids are getting into this that
they won't be sitting there with the
phone that they won't you know that that
they have you know and then just if the
conversation is not about like personal
stuff that's happening at school that's
okay yeah and I don't know um a great so
this is there's this a wonderful writer
about adolescent girls Lisa d'amour you
should look her up she's got a book
coming out and another one already out
there but she's taught me a lot she's
right for me at the Times and she one of
the things that she taught me is that a
great way to get your kids to talk to
you about what's happening in school is
for them to tell you what other people
are doing mm-hmm it's not the fairy but
well you know so I don't know are your
friends
I keep hearing that like everybody is
yes um you know if this is snapchatting
is that something you're seeing your
friend that's not a great example but is
that something you're seeing your
friends doing not are you doing it right
but you know what are you seeing because
a lot of the time you know they'll sort
of get down into it with gossiping about
one of their friends or somebody that
you both know and you can you know you
can just learn things about what cracks
that it cracks that door oh yeah and
then before they know what they're
talking about other stuff yeah I mean
that's I've noticed that like if you
just start talking about well in general
just talking about things they're
interested in but you're not even asking
them questions then there's there's a
relaxation that I think anyways we are a
big we listen to a lot of news and
podcasts in the car more so than music
but are always there lots of times now
turning it off to talk about it or
talking about it while it's still going
on I haven't had some really surprised
and one of my kids get completely
obsessed with Bernie Madoff growi yeah
it was a I think it was a Freakonomics
episode where they played part of a
podcast that was like the story and he
was like
what what Italian we had to go and get
the whole podcast and downloaded and for
like multiple rides we did nothing but
but made off and how can that happen and
he wanted to keep he wanted to find
within himself would I be the person who
would have spotted this that nobody else
spotted it like would I you know he it
was like he could see all these people
going along you know that's actually
been a theme of conversations that I've
been having with my kids for a long time
all these people that go along with
things that are wrong and then all of a
sudden you know there's are the the
record screech and everyone realizes
that it's wrong but tons of people get
caught up I don't know we talk about
that a lot I'm not quite sure what Wow
how old is he that kid is only is 12
yeah but even with the other ones you
know we're often talking about like you
know here all the all the all the guys
at that military academy that were that
had the secret Facebook page where they
were talking about whether the women
were hot like would you be the one to
say something mm-hmm that's right yeah
it's like a thought experiment right you
know so these you can it provokes a
discussion yeah and it doesn't have to
be like a personal discussion I I don't
know you know you might get the kid
who's gonna say you know my boyfriend
and I are considered but honestly you
probably won't
I mean I don't think I have that kid I
don't have any idea but well let's turn
the focus back on on the health of the
parent yes thank you so you have these
like mantras right that you that you
talk about and they'll talk about well
you can be happy when your children
aren't do you know decide what to do
then do it
soak up the good yeah I have the don't
go in that you don't have to go in there
those are really things but like are
sort of constantly playing in the
background my head seems you need the
refrigerator to remind your you know
fact I have a magnet oh you do really
yeah for each one of the mantras it's
got five Matt it's got five more easily
yeah that's cool yeah what's the one
that you think trips up parents the most
like what's the number-one thing where
you see pair
it's not going awry well this is me too
what you want now is not always what you
want later this goes to the core of what
we were just talking about because what
you want now is for your kid to be happy
what you want later is for your kid to
have like you know learned resilience
and learned to bounce back from setbacks
but you've got goodness knows you don't
want to like be supplying setbacks
that's not what any of us want and then
it goes down into sort of the very
nitty-gritty of letter layer you know
level of parenting what you want now is
to pick up the towel off the bathroom
floor
what you want later is to have a kid who
picks up the towel off the bathroom
floor and that mate that will take 12
years of daily repetition uh-huh but
it's much you know it's much easier to
just pick up the towel because what you
want now is no tell on the floor right
but you know what you the thing to do is
to go get the kid dragon it's just
easier to pick up the towel the towel
pick up the towel pick up the towel put
your shoes on put your shoes on where
are your shoes where's your shoes
where's your shoes where's your shoes
shoes away yeah you know oh yeah no
we're all we're all doing that so and
you know you're not gonna get that look
this is another mantra you're not gonna
get that right every time
mm-hmm we don't have to get it right
every time but if more often than not
you're trying to err on the side of what
you want later it's better for everybody
happier parents happier kids what do we
do about the parents that are overly
invested in their children's successes
and failures and what I mean by that is
you know the parent everything from the
parent who's on the sidelines at the
soccer game like losing his or her shed
you know we all know that person oh yeah
to the parent who is super invested in
their children's grades because they
want to make sure that their kid goes
into the right college so they can tell
their friend at the cocktail party well
we wish you like this is this is an
epidemic of parents living vicariously
through their children's experiences
which i think is just creating nothing
but suffering and harming we wish them
luck we try to find someone else to talk
at the cocktail party you know if we
talk to the parent and they're not
already doing that we talked about how
we don't want to be that parent so that
you know I can see we're assuming that
those are not us but I think what the
real question is probably what do we do
so that we're not accidentally you know
how do we know if s s right like psyche
a lot like there's obviously it's a
spectrum right so I feel like
psychologically the more dissatisfied we
are in our own lives the more we feel
like we've made compromises the more
prone we are to that predicament of
being overly invested in our yeah well
and plus it can be fun especially like
kids sports that can that can be that
can be like a real family experience you
know you can go and then maybe you end
up on the board of whatever the sport is
and you're part of like you know making
it great for the kids and you're part of
hiring the coaches and and you know
you're like really into this and all the
sudden your kids like you know I don't
want to play baseball this year and
you're just like so so we have to sort
of watch that there's involvement and
then there's over-involved right and
then there's there's over involvement so
kids will say there's some really great
research out there done by some some
coaches kids will say that their least
favorite part of a sports event is the
ride home when dad or mom has has tips
right ideas thoughts maybe you should
think about doing it this yes
constructive criticism and you know
there there actually is a right thing to
say after a game and it is I love to
watch you play would you like some ice
cream whatever it doesn't have to be ice
cream but and and it's really it's
nothing more than that if your kid wants
to analyze it's it's listening it's
supporting it's not you don't you know
you I think that the thing to look at is
nobody wants to be that parent in the
eyes of other parents but you really
don't want to be that parent in the eyes
of your kid you don't want your kid to
be the one saying I really hate the ride
home could you give me you know can I
get it ride home with someone else you
know or the one who is like I don't know
if I want to play this next year because
I
you know because I'm afraid of
disappointing my parent or because I'm
tired of I'm sort of going through that
so if we shift the lens on to how it's
affecting our relationship with our kids
that can maybe help us to step out of it
but to me probably the biggest thing the
the greatest way to keep yourself from
obsessing about like packing from your
for your kids swim tournament is to be
packing for your own swim tournament I
talked to this one parent and she had
she had high school aged triplets that
were all on the swim team and as she was
taking them to all the swim practices
and stuff like that when they were in
about middle school she had swum as a
high school turned out their coach was
starting a master's League and you know
the next so instead of sort of going
down the road of I'm gonna run all your
tournaments and I'm gonna do with the
scoring so she signed up for the Masters
lead and you know the next thing you
know what they've heard they had a they
had a meet she added me we're all
practicing at the same time and and they
have to get a ride you know they have to
they have to find their own way because
she had her own thing and that's I mean
that's really great for kids to sort of
have to you know you you want to swim
you want to do your thing mix you know
make it happen make some stuff happen
for yourself I'm not gonna facilitate
all of it I'll facilitate some of it but
because I've got my own you know I've
got my own stuff going on over there so
I think the biggest anecdote and
antidote not anecdote is having your own
stuff yeah that's a hard leap for a lot
of people though I mean it goes back to
how we open this yeah but he was like
look I'm just trying to keep it together
like my own thing like I don't have time
you know I barely have time to you know
wake up in the morning and trying to get
the kids out of the house you know I'm
exhausted before I've even started my
day well let him get themselves out of
that yeah how does that work well that
works great that's actually one of my
favorite things so I have two pieces of
advice about mornings and the first is
get more sleep which makes everybody
crazy and people just want to throw me
off of things because that's boring it's
been said but it's so true but we'll put
that aside and just go to like this
question of oh my god you have to get
your kids to school and they have to
have their backpack and their homework
and their sneakers and their violin and
their lunch and six manila folders in a
garage are of grape jelly and you have
no idea why but you know and it's 752 so
the big
thing for parents is it's a big deal to
your kid whether they get to school at
7:59 or 801 mm-hmm it's not a big deal
to you your your okay I mean maybe you
need to clock in but most of us have a
little breathing leeway there so we
don't need to we don't need to go in
there we don't need to go into that
chaos because if your kid gets to school
and they don't have their homework and
they don't have their sneakers so they
don't have their violin they don't have
their lunch and they don't have 6 min of
folders in a jar of grape jelly you'll
be fine
mmm and so will they in fact it's good
for them because then they Hey exactly
but this is not like I'm gonna make you
fail so you will learn this is just more
like hey it's morning I'll get myself
ready
I'm helping you get ready but I don't
need to be losing I don't need to be
losing my mic we don't need to do this
thing and believe me I used to do this
thing where like you screech out of the
you discreet you into the drop-off line
and you know the last possible minute
and your kid opens the door and you
scream out the window after you I told
you you'd be late and the door slams and
you drive off in a cloud of smoke you
just don't have to go to that place as
the parent you can be more you know you
can say hey I'm sorry you can't find
your lunch let me let me give you a hand
or I'm sorry you can't find your lunch
but I'm braiding your sister's hair now
I can't you know I can't I can't do that
for you um man it really sucks that you
didn't finish that homework last night
that's gonna be tough we got to get out
of the house you want a pop-tart for the
car ride I mean you can you can you
don't have to be you don't have to be in
the crazy with them instead you can be
like sort of a calm or if you're crazy
getting yourself out the door then be
crazy getting yourself out the door but
yeah so where's your thing yeah it's
it's it's not changing it's not you know
what's going on it's changing your
relationship to it your reaction to it
yeah because you don't have to stuff you
know you don't have to suffer that with
them it's not I mean it's actually
really great like you don't even have to
inflict the consequences for them being
late or not having their stuff somebody
else is going to do that this is one of
those areas of parenting where you can
sit
back and let the world take care of you
know this this is gonna be a problem
your child will have their whole life
they will always have to beat you I
don't know it's been the story of my
life anyway you always have to be
somewhere earlier than anybody wants to
be anywhere that's just for whatever
reason that's the way we have arranged
modern society so they might as well
deal with it now what about homework oh
so I don't know where that sweet spot is
that exists between being overly
involved and and allowing space for that
exploration whether it's failure or
success like did you do your homework
what do you have for homework do you
have all your books do you have
everything ready to perform your
homework where are we at with the
homework you can't do that until you've
done your homework and I see where
you're at with your homework what
happened last day did you turn that
thing in like I don't want to be that
person but I found myself being that
person and I could tell you it doesn't
work so great no it's not that great no
it's not a great for anybody and yet you
have to do some of it so every principal
and educator that I talked to wanted
parents to know one thing about homework
and that was that when we make it our
job to make sure that it gets done to
make sure that it gets back in the
backpack to make sure that it's done
correctly you know to make sure that
it's done right when we turn that into
our job we've defeated the whole purpose
of homework right like that's not what
the teacher wants that's not helpful
some teachers and I talked to one
teacher who was like I just you know I
don't even the school requires me to
give homework this is frustrating and we
can like whether or not there should be
homework is a whole different
conversation but the teacher was like
yeah this school requires me to do it
but I don't even pay any attention to it
cuz I know the parents are doing it oh
that's the worst possible thing so so so
there's there's that piece of it but on
the other hand you got to know what's
going on because if your kid has a
massive assignment due on Wednesday and
you know it's Friday but what you know
is that Tuesday has got you know
Tuesday's a busy is a big day for your
family because it's got soccer but then
you happen to have a meeting so after
soccer they have to go
home with somebody else and have dinner
and you've arranged all this stuff but
maybe they're either only vaguely aware
of that or not aware of it at all
depending on how the old they are and
then they have this thing due on
Wednesday so to some extent like
homework effects all you know it affects
the family plans it affects yeah yeah
and and you know if I don't intervene on
some level that homework won't get
looked at until Tuesday at 10 p.m. well
then it'll be at 10 p.m. to 1 a.m. and
and so I feel like I have to say look
you want to go you want to be with your
friends all weekend you can do that if
you do your if you get all of your stuff
done beforehand right it's not letting
you leave it to the last yeah that's
more like that's to me that's in the
area of like guidance around you have a
lot of stuff to do and you want to do
these things over the weekend so how are
you gonna set your depends on how old
the kid is if the kid is 8 it's probably
you have to get this done before you can
do this stuff over the weekend if the
kid is 12 it's more like if you don't
get those things done and you do this
stuff on the weekend Monday nights gonna
be ugly and yeah they're not are they
gonna get their healthy nine and a half
hours of sleep no but you want them to
have that experience at 12 not at 19
yeah so you know letting some of that
happen is okay the thing sort of the
thing to avoid is the thing where it
ends up being your fault because you
didn't tell them that there was all this
stuff going on on Tuesday and they
didn't so so there's this complicated
yeah well that's the other thing about
homework though if you are the homework
police if you are the one who's always
saying do you have it how much do you
have how long is it gonna take you is it
done let me look at it let me make sure
that it's are done right suddenly the
homework is your fault mm-hm and I hate
you because you are making me do my
homework and that isn't like it's not a
it's not a great role to be in with your
kids so the goal is to have the homework
be what the school gives the kid but
they're expected to be able to do on
their own but to provide them from the
you know the guidance to turn into
somebody that can get those things done
yeah for themselves and how you do that
kind of
you know some kids can do it really I
you know I have I've got I've got for
one of them I don't need to two of them
actually I don't ever I don't I don't
ever need to say the word homework
that's there they got this the third one
is somewhere in between and the fourth
one he spent a lot of time with his
homework he didn't spend a lot of time
doing his homework he would just exist
in the space with his homework and it
was sort of make us all really really
insane that one needed a lot more
guidance with how much you know when and
and sort of still does to some extent so
that it kind of varies from kid to kid
but the goal ideally before high school
is somebody who can figure out their own
schedule because high schools when
things stand in order for that to happen
you have to let go you do we just keep
coming back to that don't know I have
you know for the 400th time it's not
like I'm doing all this perfectly it's
just that I know what we're supposed to
do and sometimes that's really miserable
sometimes I stand in my kitchen washing
dishes going I know I was supposed to
make the kids do this like this is not
I'm not doing it right
I just want to go to bed exactly now how
let's talk about like family time and
meal time hmm how do you think about
these things how do you how do you
approach these opportunities in a
healthy way I think it is so important
to find a good space like a good rhythm
for your your your dinnertime and
perspective and in particular and this
isn't like dinnertime prevents drug use
or or whatever it's more that there's
some really great in-depth research out
there where they they watch the patterns
of families living in a house all
together and the time that you and your
partner if you have one and your kids
all spend in the same room at the same
time especially once kids start going to
full-time school is really consolidated
around the dinner hour so that's like
that's your time so whether you
whatever you do to make that look like a
good positive time that's the important
part
I mean is it hell is it important that
your family eat a healthy balanced
wonderful meal where they're all you
know singing grace beforehand I guess
that's up to you but really the key is
just that's your time like that's that's
the block that's the space people tend
to be all together so find a way to make
it to make it good and if your way of
making it good involves everybody eating
cereal that's okay because you know it's
it's the finding the good thing that
matters to me I mean or that should
matter to you that that's important this
is the time your kids are gonna look
back on and it's not any one meal it's
all of the meals it's all of the things
it's you know we always did it this way
so and so always sat here and you know
we always argued about this and if
that's your sort of that's your ritual
time it really is yeah now that's gonna
for us that's only gonna be maybe one
week yeah which I'm lamenting but the
flip side of this for me is that and
this really is about remember you've had
a lot of it yeah no we have we have but
with my 11 year old like I just you know
when when you've had all their kids that
have left the house you become much more
acutely aware just how short and
precious you know this time period is
and how you really need to take
advantage of it because it does pass so
quickly and one of the things that I
became aware of is that when like our
when our boys were living with us and we
also had our nephew living with we had a
lot of people in this house and it's
great there's a cacophony and like just
a communion you know a community kind of
spirit about it that's a beautiful and
wonderful but I found that my individual
relationship with one particular kid was
not as strong as it could be because
there was very few opportunities for
total one-on-one right and I would have
to be very intentional about carving out
time like hey you and me we're just
going to go do this
you know for it's hard to like make sure
you balance all of that yes and I didn't
always do a very good job of that but I
would always know like when I did do
that you know like hey we're just gonna
go spend the afternoon doesn't even know
it doesn't have to be some big thing
right no it's probably better if it's
not so the grocery store with yeah you
know you can pick out stuff for your
life yeah so despite the fact that we're
not going to have this total family unit
meal time I actually am excited about
having that one-on-one time like whether
it's with my older daughter downtown or
my younger daughter here like I rarely
get to be with them alone right and so
there is something cool about that that
I want to make sure that I'm paying
attention to yeah and how do I do that
in a way that's that can best foster
like our relationship and our
communication well just the doing it is
we met that's it's the it's the it's the
accumulation I mean I think we get we
put a lot of value on you know the
quality time or the one hour the one
interaction but just you know knowing
that you've got you know a whole who
knows what'll happen after this year but
you've got a whole year of you know this
is the time when I'm gonna be with this
child and this is the time when I'm
gonna be with this child and and that's
gonna turn into that year when we
ordered Chinese for every single every
Wednesday or you know that one year when
you know we had to eat dinner at 5:00
because I had something at sailor that
we had in our family it's that year when
we ate at the skinny pancake every
Tuesday and Thursday because our hockey
practices were like at 5:00 6:00 and
7:00 so somebody some chunk of the
family would sit in this crap restaurant
while other kids sort of got cycled
through you know it was a crazy
ridiculous year the memories I have yeah
when I think back on my child like I
remember my mom went to night school and
my dad would take us to the hot shops
diner and like I still remember that
like I remember that more vividly then
my mom went to college and my dad would
take me to throw food to the Ducks you
know at the in the pond at Texas Woman's
University
I'm sure that that well they probably
weren't because it was that time and
they were you know trying to make
something of themselves and that's what
they were focused on but if they thought
about it it was probably you know
feeding the Ducks is not the best use of
this child stew right I mean I think I
have this instinct like oh if I have
with I've got an afternoon and I can
just be with this child it needs to be
this epic adventure we're gonna ride
roller coasters and we're gonna we're
gonna do it it's got to be amazing so
that she'll remember it forever
and in truth like I always have to
remind myself like it has nothing to do
with any of that like you just go you
know do something let's go walk the dog
we can't control what they're gonna
remember about what we're doing either
it's just that you know we we do get to
do a lot of it and that's yeah and
that's that's really important like we
have we have a lot of time here then
like you said suddenly it's gone but you
do get to sort of accumulate this this
big nuts my family relationships are so
yeah big that intensity probably is much
more acute if you're a single parent and
your time like you only have a certain
amount of time with your like if you're
sharing custody right oh yeah yeah some
of the single parents that I've talked
to sort of see that you know you can
look at it as a boon because then you
can have your own you know you can have
your own and then you can have your kid
space and you can sort of create these
we have more opportunity to like be you
know take care of you exactly and and
then when you're with it so you it's
possible to see it as a boon not
everybody does and I don't think you
have to but um you know some people some
people sort of like well it's a silver
lining I mean you know this is not
necessarily what I planned but we're
looking at it as opportunity for my
partner to spend you know really solid
time and for me to spend really solid
times yeah I feel like so much of the
perspective the place that you're coming
from isn't necessarily about doing
things differently it's more in the how
the how how you're doing I'm like your
emotional
disposition well yeah it's how you think
about hearing these things some things
we can actually do differently I mean I
you know I still come back to not
packing in our time and trying to to
value sleep or you know they're there
you can you can look at so you can find
like the thing this is I just talked to
someone and this was so cool she like
realized that one thing that was making
her unhappiness was parent in her week
was that every Friday for whatever
reason when she picked her kid up from
school the kid that the transition was
too much and I I've had this the
transition from school to home can be
huge and the kid would just lose it in
the car just you know yell at her just
this really unpleasant ride so this was
a pretty little kid he was on six so she
said to him one day I noticed that every
Friday when I pick you up you're angry
like you have a tantrum and that's
actually not working from my schedule
Friday afternoons not a good time so I
was thinking could we schedule the
tantrum for Friday evening because I
think that would be better for both of
and the kid you know laughed and then
they made this sort of big joke and when
he got in the car on Friday she would
say um so remember we're scheduling the
tantrum for later and then like later he
would have a big fake tantrum so that I
thought that was this great example of
like looking at a thing that was making
her and her kid unhappy and finding a
thing to do differently so we can do
that like around small things but you're
right that a lot of being a happier
parent is about your mindset it's about
choosing how to look at the experiences
that you're having and choosing how you
know how to interact with your kids and
sort of deciding big a big part of being
happier is what you pay attention to its
well you know it's deciding to pay
attention to the things that that are
happy mm-hmm how do you think about
respecting your kids privacy and when
it's appropriate to you know impede on
that like if you feel like something
isn't going right like do you look at
their phone do you never look like how
does that how does all of that like I've
never had to really you know I've never
gone into my kids phones right I mean we
have good healthy communication around
that but I'm also not
naive Fran how about what's going on
online and so I'm always wondering you
know where that like kind of lined yeah
I'm I am I'm not an expert in that I to
have not had that experience
I've talked you know I've interviewed
and I've researched and I've looked into
it and the biggest thing that I've that
I've found and the advice that I've
found is that if you're gonna spy on
your kids they should know that you're
doing like so you know if you're
tracking their phone or their movements
or whatever they should know that you're
doing it and they should know why that
there should be an open communication
about it you know your I know that you
are with these people and I know that
they are smoking pot and therefore you
know I'm gonna be smelling your clothes
when you get home or you know therefore
I'm gonna be and I told you that I want
to be you to be in this place and I know
that sometimes you've gone somewhere
else so I'm gonna be watching where your
phone is and if you turn it off there's
going to be consequences but I too
haven't had that experience yet so I
don't know that there's you know sort of
one-size-fits-all advice about that yeah
it's tricky it's it gets even more
complicated when you know all these kids
have their they have their other private
hidden accounts on all these social
media platforms you know they have their
one account that their parents know
about that's whitewashed because they
know their parents are looking at it
right but then there's the other account
right and well and that's the argument
for not looking at it right it's sort of
more like you know and then I mean if if
you can be in that place and that's I
mean it's a luxury it's the it's the
luxury of the parent who doesn't have
reason to suspect that their kid is
putting themselves in danger with
behavior but if you can be in the place
of you know I'm not paying attention
your social media accounts I'm not
watching your every move because I've
you've always been you haven't shown me
that I need to and as long as you don't
show me that I need to I'm not gonna be
that parent and this is like you know
this is kind of the conversation to have
about I mean we were talked about having
the conversation about what other kids
it's also fun to have the conversation
about what other parents do those other
those bad other parents of your friends
that are the parents that would spy on
you I just want you to know that I don't
do those things because you've never
given me reason to think that I had to
and I think that's great and you know
what you're kind of also saying there's
and if you give me a reason you know
maybe that would change but you know if
we're in that position where we don't
have to then I guess the hope is that
the kid can have just the one social
media account and be reasonably
responsible you know that I think yeah
we hear a lot of horror stories but yeah
I remember you only hear the horror
stories yeah it's not like you know
there's a hundred thousand kids who are
just snapchatting themselves pictures of
themselves making pouty duck faces don't
make the news it's the one who's you
know snapchatting their private parts
that does yeah III think even more kind
of pervasive than that is just this idea
that I don't know that we fully
appreciate that I mean when you're you
know a young adolescent there's nothing
more important than how you fit into
your social network like the stakes are
so high emotionally and if you're not
quite fitting in the fact that you can
go on these social media platforms and
watch in real time the people in your
social network enjoying their lives
without you or perhaps even at your
expense is so psychologically damaging
and it hasn't been around long enough
yet such that I think we can properly
gauge the impact of that great but the
extent to which you know a marginalized
person can have that marginalization
exacerbated by these tools that seem
innocuous and are kind of intended to
bring us closer together
that are that are really you know
wreaking emotional havoc on young people
there is a flip side which is that that
marginalized kid can connect with other
marginalized truth you know of course
you know if you're the one I
you know the one LGBTQ kid in you're
very tiny you know 60 person high school
in northern rural New Hampshire you can
find a whole network of other you know
you can reach out you can find those
people if you're the only kid who is
super super super different interested
in coins and all your friends think that
that's completely nerdy you can find a
world of people that are interested in
coins so there is a flip side that is
you know the same kid who feels
marginalized and alone where they are
now can see that there's another place
to be and can work to get there
that's it's true it is true I think what
happens is well this is just a larger
observation of just parenting and having
kids like we live in a fear-based
environment that fear is is you know
instilled in us from every source of
media that we that we absorb throughout
our day and it spills into you know how
we pair it because we're terrified we're
either gonna be a bad parent or we're
going to put our kid in danger or that
our child's pain is our own pain or a
reflection of our failures and all of
this is like this waterfall spilling
onto our kids meanwhile we're not taking
care of ourselves because that feels
indulgent really like we're not being a
bad parent and we're falling behind and
all of these sorts of things so what's
great about the book is it's like it's
saying stop you do have to take care of
yourself that's the best way forward but
it can be so hard to break that that
cycle of fear when it's so constantly
reinforced there's a lot especially
around the screens and the social media
there's a lot to be afraid of just
because it's not part of our own
experience and I think it's kind of
interesting to look at the history here
so we are the maybe the second
generation of parents for whom we can
look at our kids experience and go well
that looks a lot like mine like you know
I went to elementary school and then I
went to middle schooler junior high and
then I went to high school and then I
went to college and that that and you
know I and what you're doing sort of
what you're marching through looks
like what I did our parents you know
like our our mothers a lot of them
weren't necessarily you know sure they
maybe they went to elementary school
junior high high school maybe college
but they weren't expected to excel in
math and sciences and maybe they weren't
expected to have a job when they got
like there their experience of
adolescence and childhood had a
different flair to it
their parents unless you are from a
historically wealthy family probably
didn't even maybe they didn't go to high
school they probably didn't go to
college you know historically and then
and then you sort of get immigrant
parents who were looking at kids having
the point is we're the first generation
to look at our kids and expect them to
have the same experience that we did but
they're not going to it's it's not as
much the same as we think that it is so
we sort of have this weird fear around I
need to make this the same I need to
make your experience look like mine I
need to control it and I think our pair
previous generations didn't they didn't
even have that expectation they were
sort of looking and going well you're
going to high school and I didn't go to
high school so that's different you're
just gonna have to learn to figure that
out yourself it was like a different
just a just a different space so we're
coming at it and we're looking at that
and we're not you know we do we don't
like all those areas where it's where
it's different those are the those are
the scary bits I think that's a great
point and I also think that we're
judging we're judging the kids through
the prism of our own experience were
laying on top of that that expectation
of sameness and at the same time we're
also measuring them against a yardstick
that I'm not sure is really going to be
all that relevant right in terms of what
they're what they really are going to
need to be happy and successful in this
rapidly advancing moral right I mean if
you can somehow just step back from your
own like if you can go back into your
history and think about like you know
you're in my case say I have this uncle
and he you know he went to college but
he couldn't quite me just and then he
went and found himself and they need to
submit eventually he went to vet school
and became a very
but it took you know there was this
winding road and you probably have high
school friends that had you know the
winding road they drove a van and veil
for four years before they you know
before they found it a country a company
or they drove a van and veil for four
years before they decided they really
loved driving a van and veil for four
years and they got married and they
raised their kids while driving a van
and veil for four years and that's what
they did and it worked out you know we
sort of able to accept that variation on
working out for other people but for our
kids it's really scary we would like
them you know we think we would like
them to go elementary school middle
school high school college graduate
school consulting firm I don't I don't
know that makes us feel saving yeah
after ball and we love to go oh my god
did you hear so and so I was driving a
van was he doing and then he founds the
company and the company does the IPO and
you're like it's not amazing you know
it's it's all filtered through this
weird
judgment machine that we all have built
into our yeah DNA I guess yeah and I
think we you know we easily lose sight
you know we've talked a lot about Susie
the neighbor down the street who's doing
all the things right and you know has
the best Instagram pictures and stuff
like that I think we forget that we are
all doing something super cool like
we're all doing something we've all got
our thing so maybe your thing is that
you know every weekend your whole family
gets up and goes to church all together
but a lot of families do you know a lot
of families don't do that maybe your
thing is that you're hiking all the 4000
footers with your your kids that's a
thing up in New England where we are
maybe your thing is you know maybe
you're a family of traveling circus
artists and therefore your kids are
being raised as traveling circus artists
but if you're not a family of traveling
circus artists you can't recreate that
so it's really important to be like what
you know when other people when other
people look at your Instagram what other
people look at your life they are saying
I wish I baked cookies every week with
my kid or you know oh I I wish that um
you know my kid and I were taking
pictures outside of every
shop in you know across New England
while they went to hockey oh I wish that
my kid and I had dedicated a summer to
finding the best burger in New Jersey um
you know you're doing your thing but the
thing is your thing doesn't look cool
because this is your thing that's a
boring thing but everybody else you know
like we all have a thing we just you
have to you have to find a way to sort
of value what it is that you're doing
with your kids and not worry quite so
much about what other people are doing
with their yeah it's so true and so hard
to do it is hard to do in all the
research that you did for this book what
was what what was something that most
surprised you oh what did you not expect
this is actually there's a really clear
answer to that so one of the pieces of
research that I did myself was to work
with a professor at Fordham University
and we created an academically
peer-reviewed appropriate I would call
it a survey but I think there's a better
word for it study in which we got a
thousand people who were you know
demographically reflective of the United
States not a thousand of my closest
Facebook friends to respond to questions
around happiness and parenting and we
use the academic measure for parent for
happiness which is satisfactory and it's
how good do you think you are at this
thing and so people is that Gretchen
Rubin approved probably is but yeah
Gretchen does her own stuff and oh my
gosh it's amazing anyway so we did this
thing and one of the things we had on
there as well as lots of you know
questions about well well how do you
decide what your kids have to eat and
how do you feel about how much homework
they have and how do you feel about your
involvement we had this open-ended
question we actually had two and one was
what do you like most and the other one
was what do you like least and you could
just write so many people responded with
some variation of the word discipline
then I went back and read through our
survey to make sure we weren't secretly
cueing them like did we use the word
discipline 46 times or something there
was nothing you know I couldn't find
anything like a third about a third of
the answers accumulated around this idea
of I hate discipline of my kids
I hate making my kids follow the rules I
hate it when my kids do something wrong
and I have to punish them I hate having
to come up with consequences like there
was this real consensus that that was
the thing and I really think that if you
had surveyed our parents they would not
have said that I don't know what they
would have said but I don't think it
would have been that really interesting
bother them to discipline oh right
so what do you make of that I mean what
does that mean well my theory is that
one of the things that's hard is that we
are expected to have disciplined kids
who behave in public spaces and you know
act like disciplined kids but there's no
consensus anymore on how we're supposed
to get there like when what our parents
were parenting and when we were being
raised there was this more authoritative
culture authoritarian culture where the
idea was if your child yeah if your
child does something wrong there is a
consequence and that will teach your
child not to do the wrong thing and
whether actually that didn't necessarily
work and it's got its problems but it
was a thing like there was an
expectation so when your child didn't do
the right thing you knew what you were
gonna do um you know you were gonna
grant them or you were gonna take away
the television or you were gonna you
know not let them go to the dance you
knew but now we don't really have an
agreement around that now it's sort of
well you know do you have a conversation
with them is this a learning experience
do you try to you know do you try to
talk to them what works for your kid and
that's actually I mean it's a better
space and it's confusing but it's also
same sense it's upsetting and if you if
you well I have a kid who's who's tough
and who has emotional challenges and one
of the things that we discovered for her
with this is the consequences just
completely backfired so we would be in a
public space and this child would do
something you know horrific that would
cause everyone else to sort of turn and
start waiting for you to impose some
form of you know terrible consequence
and you know and and would observe us
sort of just standing there and watching
the key and you it feels terrible to be
that parent who's sort of getting all
the the burden of the opéra Batian you
know everyone
on the airplane and it wasn't airplanes
are tough but you know everyone around
you expecting sort of waiting for you to
do something and you knowing that that
there's something that they that your
best choice is to ride this out or even
maybe to you know what looks like reward
the child okay here why don't you you
know I know that you're feeling bad have
a lollipop and we'll talk about this
when we get home and that looks like
terrible parenting but maybe it's the
right thing for you so anyway I think
that makes that lack of a consensus
around what we are supposed to do and
what we're expected to do and what the
people around us will approve of our
doing makes that a really stressful yeah
it's so we second-guess every move that
we make and yeah yeah yeah we have
mental conversations well I was just
doing that because yeah it's it's um it
can be really so that's my thought is
that that is a really stressful area
because we're not necessarily you know
we just don't have an answer we hate
that we don't like not having answers
right I don't like it I feel like so
much of what you're saying in this book
boils down to like just chill the f out
yeah a little bit right I'm okay you're
okay yeah no it really is we need to
just take a step back and take some deep
breaths and look around and notice that
we're safe we're secure there aren't you
know most of the things that we think
are chasing after our kids the terrible
things that are happening to them that
they're not in the first grade class
with their best friend or they didn't
get into the college that they want to
it's not a tiger it's not the end of the
world
mhm you know it's okay it's gonna work
out and once we can if we can do that we
can just be in a much much nicer place
for everybody yeah do you are you
familiar with Susan David yes I love
Susan do so she's kind of all about like
emotional emotional agility which is
basically you know instilling resilience
I mean she talks about it within
ourselves but certainly I think it's
important the more you kind of
understand about that it can it can help
inform a healthier parenting approach to
instill that right and the kids right
yeah no I think I think it's great and
it's
it's just so important to find you know
some some perspective on all the things
that get us you know put our shoulders
into our ears and really freak us out
yeah so what's uh what are you working
on now what's next you're not doing that
are you still writing for the New York
Times I write for the New York Times
sort of when the opportunity arises I'm
not not a regular columnist anymore and
I'm not editing anymore that was so much
fun but it was time to move on you know
happier parents don't spend their whole
lives writing about parenting actually
what's next for me is fiction I'm really
uh yeah I'm I'm moving out of the
nonfiction realm for the moment I've got
a novel with my agent but that may end
up in a drawer and I may start working
on the next one but I'm gonna just work
on talking about this book and getting
out there and enjoying this experience
and sort of having this conversation
with as many people as I can while I do
some different creative things yeah
cool and you host your podcast am
writing right the great jessica leigh
yes i think one of the most that's just
a completely brilliant like personal
level one of the most brilliant things
that she and i ever did was to create a
podcast that wasn't about we you know we
both write a lot about parenting and
family mm-hmm creating a podcast that
wasn't about that was perhaps the
smartest thing because i think you know
we will we'll both evolve in terms of
our journalistic careers but we'll
always be writers right so that's what
we talked about in our podcast writing
you can do that when we're 80 it's cool
and how's life on the farm life on the
farm is really good that's the society
work it you live on a farm in New
Hampshire fully functioning as in let's
see as in they're stacking hay without
me right now I would say today is my
kids for kids
oh do that they have to yeah that's it
yeah I mean that's you know that's
actually the answer to how to get kids
to do any horse is you know it's not
it's not optional in our family whether
or not you go down and stack hey cuz
there's hay and it has to be stacked he
stacked yeah yeah so I had to I had to
get some other people I mean we have a
barn manager we farm with other people
and our community comes together
to to do that part of it the hang but
sort of long-distance managing them
which is unusual but you can't schedule
hey you can't control hey hey must be
cut when there are enough sunny days to
cut the hay and unfortunately that
coincided with me being in California
right so that's are they doing it oh
you're in your absence oh yeah and what
I mean they have to it's cut once you've
cut it there are no alternatives to
bearing it is this do do you approach
this with the carrot or the stick or
some combination thereof I will pay you
if you were my child to help with the
hang if you are doing the work that I
would put it of an adult so I am now to
the point where my youngest kids are 12
and they do get paid little to work well
two of them do the one who rides horses
and works at the barn and then is very
integrally involved with the farm
doesn't get paid and money because she
gets paid in right sort of you know
doing what she loves and then my 17 year
old gets paid a lot more because he's
much more useful when it comes to
hanging than I am he's 6 feet tall and
you know can throw a hay bale into a
truck whereas I have to like sort of
heft it up gently and sound so he gets a
full man saturated carrots of varying
sizes carrots of varying sizes but you
know they haven't they haven't always
and there's a lot of farm work that they
do that doesn't come with any kind of
carrot it just is what it is right cool
all right well we got to wrap this up
but let's leave people with some
inspiration a little nugget of wisdom
for the parent out there that still
suffers for the parent that just can't
they just can't get past the obligations
of the day just can't wrap their head
around the indulgent idea that they're
that they that they can and should
exercise a little self-control czar
it goes happier famine happier kid happy
family happier parent happier kid
happier family and if you need to I mean
people who spend time on their own
happiness they make better employees
they're healthier they live longer
there's a lot of research around this
that it is worthwhile to put some time
into making yourself a positive members
of society as well as a contributing
member of society powerful KJ thank you
so much thank you delight to talk to you
how do you feel
this was great good awesome the book is
how to be a happier parent available
everywhere you buy fine books
is there an audio book oh yeah and is
good I did I learned a lot from reading
it it was interesting about well I
learned a lot about about writing a book
and reading an audio book but also yes
in rereading the Taurus chapter I spent
a lot of time going oh oh we should be
doing that oh geez and then I went home
and we made that better so yeah I
learned and reading my audio book that's
very difficult to read an audio book
okay awkward learned I learned that I
cannot pronounce the word towards
towards Co WRAT you say towards towards
ya but I can't say that oh you can yeah
I can say I would in conversation I
would say Texas thing it must be I would
say toward I wouldn't say it with the S
but I was wrote it with the S and then
there I was and I can't tell you how
often I use that word it's just you know
ready since your biggest problem you're
doing well yeah I should be happy yeah
cool do you have any do you got you do
public speaking stuff or any book
signings or anything like that like if
people want to want to reach out to you
connect with you how do they do that
where is the best place I am really easy
to find KJ Dell Antonio dot-com I do do
some speaking not a whole lot because I
live in rural New Hampshire and it's
hard but I do get it out there once in a
while and you know I'm very active like
you can always find me online yeah and
listen to our podcast please and please
say hi to just for me I will do that
alright cool come back and talk to me
again Thanks cool thank you
peace
[Music]